[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique une fois par mois en plateau
et prochainement chaque semaine pour
suivre au mieux les différentes
campagnes électorales je reçois
aujourd'hui olivier de la faire
concilier départementale des yvelines
conseiller municipal de versailles il
avait souhaité obtenir à l'investiture
de républicains pour les législatives
sur la première circonscription sa
formation lui a préféré françois xavier
bellamy soutenu par le député sortant
françois de mazières olivier de mazières
va-t-il malgré tout se présentait
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue en plateau
nous allons revenir sur l'actualité
politique locale nationale et donc tout
d'abord cette question serez vous
candidat même sans l'investiture des
républicains écoutez pour le moment il
n'est pas question d'être d'être
candidat je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est
surtout question de savoir un peu ce qui
s'est passé on a eu une commission
d'investiture qui s'est réunie très
rapidement sans avoir étudié ans j'ai
envie de dire l'ailé les clés les quatre
candidatures qui était présente
on peut se poser la question aujourd'hui
j'avais une telle méthode je conteste
pas le résultat on est bien d'accord
mais ce contexte la méthode de méthode
est encore
faisable aujourd'hui surtout quand on a
eu un élan de démocratie comme on a pu
avoir avec les primaires
les primaires de la droite et du centre
où on a voulu aujourd'hui je veux
pouvoir choisir notre candidat
on revient finalement locales sur des
situations un peu plus vite que c'est un
peu obscures le choix s'est fait j'en
veux dire un petit peu oui on vous l'a
expliqué comment ce choix donc ce sera
françois xavier qui sera le candidat des
républicains sur cette première
circonscription je reprécise pour ceux
qui n'habitent pas sur ce secteur qui
couvre à versailles
montigny-le-bretonneux notamment où là
on sait comment cette décision j'ai reçu
un coup de fil du du maire pour me dire
qu'il y avait une commission nationale
d'investiture et qui s'étaient réunis et
qu'ils avaient choisi françois xavier
bellamy en revanche j'ai jamais eu de
j'ai jamais été auditionné j'ai jamais
eu de respect de réponse à ma
candidature comme les autres candidats
ce que je regrette un peu quand on fait
une acte de candidature c'est bien de
respecter les candidats notamment
respecter les élus on est dans des
parties on travaille pour notre parti et
on s'aperçoit finalement que
on prend pas en considération les élus
qui ont fait une demande au sein du
parti ça ça fait partie de la démocratie
on a une démocratie moderne je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il fallait il fallait
aussi pouvoir aller plus loin que de
simplement imposer le droit de suite qui
aujourd'hui font moins d'appuis le plus
grand chose à dire quand on a eu une
primaire aujourd'hui à droite comme on a
eu précédemment
le droit de suite on a combattu françois
de mazières et moi on l'a combattu
france basée en 2008 mois en 2011
voilà je regrette qu'on en arrive encore
ac à ces méthodes françois-xavier
bellamy et sans étiquette qui est au
conseil municipal de versailles depuis
2008 il a 31 ans et s'est fait connaître
notamment pour différentes prises de
position dans lé cadre de débats d'idées
normalien agrégé enseignant de
philosophie c'est un jeune loup c'est
comme ça qu'il est présenté de la droite
catholique conservatrice proche de la
manif pour tous aussi ce que vous
estimez que c'est un bon candidat
ah mais il ce malgré françois xavier est
un est un garçon charmant est
extrêmement brillant c'est assez c'est
certainement un très bon candidat
moi j'en veux dire ma candidature elle
était je pensais pouvoir venir
aujourd'hui parler de ma candidature
mais elle était surtout la démonstration
de 2,2 dans un homme de terrain
c'est vrai que j'étais soutenu par
beaucoup d'élus de autour de versailles
les 42 conseillers départementaux de pro
deux parlementaires et parce qu'il me
voit sur le terrain parce qu'ils savent
que je travaille aussi pour les
yvelinois et pour les versaillais
je crois que c'était ça aussi c'était
c'était toute la candidature de toute la
la le pardon la campagne de l'est
françois fillon aussi qu était de dire
moi j'ai fait 80 sur le terrain j'ai
compris le problème des français mais
moi ce que j'avais envie de dire c'était
ça fait longtemps que je suis sur le
terrain ça fait longtemps que
travaillait aussi pour ma ville pour mon
département et je pensais avoir compris
aussi les problématiques des yvelinois
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
voulais être candidat à cette primaire
il ya une autre circonscription dans les
yvelines où il ya eu du changement en
tout cas il y en aura c'est la troisième
c'est celle du chesnay j'aimerais aussi
vous y faire revenir c'est henri guaino
qui est député sortant il a été écarté
par les républicains pour des propos
notamment à l'encontre de la primaire et
puis son envie de se présenter aussi en
dehors de son parti il a donc été mis à
l'écart il n'aura pas l'investiture des
républicains là vous comprenez ce choix
aussi alors je comprends le choix
effectivement on soit pour moi soit on
est dans le parti il soit on ne l'est
pas quand on veut avoir l'investiture du
du parti je pense que c'est important de
pouvoir l'être
c'est vrai je regrette je ne comprends
pas forcément aujourd'hui qu'on ne vend
plus prendre des décisions à l'écart de
candidats qui sont pas forcément dans le
parti ou contre le parti
on se demande à quoi ça sert de
travailler pour le parti de faire les
campagnes pour le parti pour aller
choisir des candidats qui ne sont pas
forcément dans le parti soutenue par des
gens qui sont pas forcément non plus
dans le parti c'est un peu compliqué et
effectivement on le voit sur la
troisième on n'a pas pris de décision
parce qu'on a laissé le temps aux
candidats de pouvoir de pouvoir faire
laure color janvier à leur campagne
interne au sein du parti je regrette
qu'on n'ait pas fait la même chose en
bas dans la première ses conceptions ça
veut dire quoi que globalement sur les
investitures la façon dont ça se déroule
avec l'équipe fillon ou avaient des
inquiétudes et questions spatiales sur
l'équipe fillon je pense qu'on reste
aujourd'hui dans les vieux
fonctionnement de nos de nos de nos
partis quoi
l'excellent moment de démocratie moderne
qu'on avait pu avoir avec la primaire on
le fait sur le cours national devant la
caméra mais on ne sait plus on ne sait
plus en local
sur le terrain aussi un peu dommage pour
succéder à henri guaino ce sera
peut-être philippe brillault il a été il
a fait acte de candidature le maire du
chesnay je vous propose de l'écouter il
était l'invité était invité sur notre
plateau cette semaine guaino a plein de
qualités c'est une pratique qui est
instruit ou autre mais il n'est pas sur
le terrain
il n'écoute pas les gens comment
voulez-vous à l'assemblée nationale
proposer des lois qui ne sont pas en
rapport avec les attentes des gens
aujourd'hui moi je considère que ma
candidature et celle je pense de
l'expérience et de la proximité des gens
si la droite veut séduire les gens il
faut qu'elle change de techniques faut
qu'elle change de méthode c'est des gens
de terrain qui doivent y aller c'est la
raison pour laquelle je fais que de
quantité que la suite pour vous vous
attendez cette décision à la dernière
minute pour cette investiture au mais
moi je pense que vous serez candidat si
vous ne m'avez pas la médiature même
sans investiture
bien sûr donc contre votre famille
politique tendu tout qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une famille aujourd'hui une famille
c'est quelqu'un qui est solidaire de ses
membres s'ils sont solidaires de ses
membres ils me demanderont investiture
henri guaino qui a annoncé sur notre
plateau que même s'il n'avait pas
l'investiture il se présenterait je
reviens à ma question du début de
l'émission est ce que ce sera bien pour
nous écouter
pour le moment je sais ce que c'est en
réflexion je réfléchis 7,7 cette
décision est arrivée tellement vite
j'étais un peu pris de court pour tout
vous dire donc j'y réfléchissais exclu
vraiment rien maintenant je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait un débat avec avec les
dirigeants du parti avec les dirigeants
de l'équipe fillon
et puis et puis on verra les choses mais
disent que rien c'est vrai que c'est ce
que j'ai combattu mois en 2000 en 2011
ce droit de suite je j'ai un peu de mal
je vous avais tout cas cependant nous
évoquons la question des législatives il
ya tout de même une inconnue de taille
en selle verdict de la présidentielle
c'est une élection incertaine encore
plus cette année que les autres fois
avec de multiples rebondissements et
notamment la sphère françois fillon les
affaires françois fillon aujourd'hui est
ce que françois fillon doit jeter
l'épongé selon vous non je crois pas
sincèrement je crois pas parce tout
d'abord ça a été un excellent candidat
il a vraiment fait une campagne superbe
où il a réussi réussir à rassembler
toute la droite sur un projet et
aujourd'hui on voudrait nous faire
croire avec
avec une force et
mais alain un lynchage qui est qu'on a
qu'on n'a jamais vus enfin je veux dire
sans précédent et on veut nous faire
croire que ce n'est pas le candidat
idéal
moi je crois aujourd'hui que c'est le
candidat idéal je pense que c'est le
candidat qui dérange le candidat qui
dérange la gauche assez certain où on
sent la faiblesse de la gauche on voit
un candidat frondeurs reprendre le bourg
à gauche franchement après une gauche
très divisés comme on peut la voir
aujourd'hui je peux comprendre qu'ils
s'attaquent aux candidats à droite
maintenant la façon dans laquelle s'est
fait je trouve ça un peu ignoble je juge
pas les faits je crois surtout les
enquêtes ariane près des hangars
évidemment il y aura pas d'étape
maintenant maintenant à priori c'était
pas il n'y avait pas une faute
juridique en fait il ya peut-être une
faute morale mais ya pas une faute
juridique
donc j'ai envie j'ai envie de pouvoir
penser qu' on doit aller on doit aller
plus loin aujourd'hui effet et passer
outre ce genre de 2,2 de calomnies qui
sont régulières tous dans tous les jeux
dans le nesc et peut s'en remettre pour
relancer la campagne parce que là on
parle on en a besoin on en a besoin on
va pas remettre un candidat on va
permettre un candidat trois mois deux
mois et demi avant avant l'élection j'ai
envie de dire de sassari ça serait
absurde
donc il faut vraiment aujourd'hui qu'on
reparte avec le candidat il a fait une
très belle campagne il a montré qu'ils
avaient des réformes importantes à faire
en france je sais que c'est des réformes
qui dérange certains français mais mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix quand on
a un pays dans une situation aussi
calamiteuse qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
on voit des gens qui ont de moins en
moins de moyens on voit les classes
moyennes qui ont de moins en moins de
moyens et on voit toutes nos toutes nos
richesses partir à l'international cc
c'est d'une tristesse épouvantable
olympique qui qui qui va kiffer qui va
mourir dans le certains parlent de
certains parle de cabale véritablement
contre la droite contre françois fillon
c'est comme ça que vous le mettez moi je
pense que c'est vraiment comme ça que
l'analyse venu c'est vraiment comme ça
qu'ils analysent après on peut on peut
rentrer sur plein de débat on supprime
ou non cumul c'est très bien mais est-ce
que aussi peut-être
on peut revoir aussi le le le mandat de
l'élu est ce que c'est normal aussi
qu'un un parlementaire peu chien 1900
euros
quand vous avez un directeurs
d'administrations ou un sous directeur
d'administration qui est payé entre 8000
et 15000 euros voilà posons-nous aussi
les élémentaires c'est une question je
pense qu'il faut qu'on se sera difficile
à faire comprendre aux français dans ce
gala dion-viens accord alors les
parlementaires ou les élus en général
non non vous vous estimez enfin on peut
vouloir demain avoir un maire d'une
ville de 30 mille habitants qui bosse à
plein temps le soir le week-end et qui
est payé 1500 euros c'est aussi un vrai
sujet aujourd'hui peut-être posons nous
les vraies questions aussi sur le statut
d'élu on arrivera peut-être pas des
situations comme ça sur la situation des
présidentielles donc c'est difficile
lundi voir clair sur le résultat final
est du côté de lui des y du centre on
évoque la tentation macron aussi un
rassemblement autour du centre je vous
propose d'évoquer cette question
justement est de voir la manière dont
s'approche ce rapprochement entre l'ue
dei et le modem dans le département des
yvelines
il ya quelques semaines les deux
formations
cérémonie de voeux en commun pour 2017
le reportage soutien d'alain juppé le
modem avait pris ses distances à l'issue
de la primaire de la droite pour laisser
planer le doute d'une candidature de
françois bayrou
du côté de lui dès la désignation de
françois fillon avait aussi entraîné une
division au sein des militants dans les
yvelines les deux formations ont donc
décidé d'officialiser leur rapprochement
ce début d'année autour d'une cérémonie
de voeux commune au niveau local on n'a
vraiment pas le plus souvent une feuille
de papier à cigarette d'épaisseur entre
nos convictions et le point de vue qu'on
a sur les différents projets locaux
départementaux régionaux et communaux
bien sûr ça fait longtemps qu'on se dit
quand même qu'on a toutes ces valeurs
qu'on a en commun il faudrait qu'on les
porte sur le territoire c'est vraiment
pour le territoire qu on le fait parce
que la politique voyez bien la politique
au niveau national ça commence à devenir
un peu délétère il ya des affaires qui
sortent les uns les unes derrière les
autres europe et environnement l'heure
est donc à l'union avec des valeurs
communes et pourquoi pas un
rassemblement autour d'un autre candidat
pour la présidentielle
macron séduit c'est dû beaucoup y
compris dans de grands faut pas non plus
faire de langue de bois pour autant
voilà il ya une méthode à l'évidence qui
est intéressante mais il y a
il ya un contenu que qui est encore
imprécis à l'évidence
donc on va voir ce qu'ils proposent ça
interpelle c'est intéressant
les jeunes me suivent il a amené un vent
nouveau de l'air frais donc on peut pas
faire comme s'il n'existait pas c'est
pas possible et pourquoi pas des
candidatures communes aux législatives
une question que doivent évidemment se
poser les responsables des mouvements
lors des européennes de 2014 les listes
udi modem avait totalisé 14 % dans les
yvelines
derrière l'ump et le fn mais devant le
parti socialiste s'il udi décide d'un
ralliement massif verrière par exemple
emmanuel macron ça va handicaper encore
un peu plus la candidature des
républicains certainement certainement
aux leurres nettoie aux centristes qui
sont tentés de sept candidats
oui oui déjà un je pense qu emmanuel
macron c'est quand même l'échec du
quinquennat de françois hollande
il a fait tout le tout la toute
l'économie il était ministre après
l'économie et on voit aujourd'hui qu'on
a la pire économie de la vème république
donc c'est le pire résultat qu'on ait pu
avoir voudrait nous faire croire que
l'un d'entre eux emmanuel macron c'est
le sauveur c'est le sauveur de la france
l'année prochaine moi j'y crois pas en
revanche que je je je crois certainement
c'est que et avec lui dit on à crème un
certain nombre de valeurs communes avec
avec les républicains et notre objectif
c'est bien de battre la gauche qui nous
a mis dans une situation déplorable
depuis ce depuis cinq ans donc si on
veut nous dire aujourd'hui il faut se
diviser non je pense qu'aujourd'hui faut
vraiment se rassembler la preuve de ce
on est dans ce reportage nous on dit
bien qu'il faut aller se rassembler
derrière derrière un candidat déjà
françois fillon d'ailleurs on a fait
cette primaire de la droite et du centre
non il n'y avait pas de candidat du
centre peut-être mais aujourd'hui ils en
étaient tous d'accord pour dire qu'il
fallait se rassembler derrière un leader
on là il a été élu à quatre millions de
2 2 avec 4 millions d'électeurs s'est
pas l'autre mais voilà je pensais pas
c'est passionnant
l'apparition passion globalement mais en
l'occurrence n'est pas neutre pour
valider un programme ayant produit enfin
est un élu dans ce monde il a pendant
une dizaine de minutes si nous allons
accueillir sur ce plateau un jeune
lycéen il votera pour la première fois
cette année il va nous donner son regard
sur l'actualité politique nous
poursuivons pour l'instant cette édition
avec olivier de la sphère conseiller
municipal les républicains sur
versailles conseiller départemental est
justement l'actualité politique c'est
aussi ce rapprochement qui s'opère entre
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine en
établissement public commun été créée
avec des premières tâches à assumer avec
un budget aussi comment est ce que vous
faites partie des sceptiques au sein de
l'assemblée départementale des yvelines
il y en a quelques uns on évoquait
philippe brillault tout à l'heure il
fait aussi partie de ceux qui s'opposent
à cette à ce rapprochement et lindsey
nous est ce qu'au contraire vous êtes
convaincus du projet alors moi ce que je
veux que je voudrais dire c'est que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui à rien de jouer
dans ce rapprochement des yvelines avec
avec les hauts-de-seine en revanche ce
qui est important c'est de pouvoir
étudier toutes les solutions pour demain
parce qu'on a un territoire
aujourd'hui qui est attractif on a un
beau territoire des yvelines il faut pas
oublier que d'abord un il ya des enjeux
économiques derrière qui sont forts
quand on a une baisse des dotations
considérable du gouvernement est à la
fois quand on a une hausse des dépenses
sociales importantes
on est en droit de rechercher
bada faire des économies et puis de
rechercher les solutions pour que demain
on sera encore plus performant dans nos
missions
on peut dire aujourd'hui que les
yvelines et un était un département très
bien géré et a très bien fonctionné mais
avec la baisse des dotations de l'état
quand on a perdu 200 millions d'euros
cette année
ça nous a effectivement bien handicapé
sur un certain nombre de nos missions
donc aujourd'hui l'idée peut-être
d'aller chercher avec un autre
département des mutualisations de moyens
pour pouvoir encore faire mieux et
pouvoir continuer le service qu'on peut
apporter aux yvelinois sa part il a
remis ça peut permettre des économies on
a créé justement l'établissement public
interdépartemental dans lequel on a déjà
mutualiser des démissions
mais je crois déjà on verra on verra
d'ici d'ici six mois un an quels en sont
les fruits c'est une c'est une
construction qui récente et quels en
sont les fruits est ce qu'on a
réellement fait des économies avec ça je
pense que là on pourra prendre des
vraies décisions
est ce que aujourd'hui il enfin après
effectivement les yvelines c'est un
superbe département on a attaché à notre
département des yvelines
tous les français ont montré qu'ils
étaient très attachés à leur département
maintenant le département des yvelines
c'est un département récent c'est un
département qui date de 1964 avant
c'était la seine et oise qui a été
reconstruit je pense qu'aujourd'hui faut
pas se fermer il faut pas se fermer à
toutes les solutions on en plus on a de
ces problèmes de métropole du grand
paris il faut savoir que les avis ne
sont pas dans la métropole du grand
paris mais justement il a en tout cas
c'est ce que les opposants nous explique
à ce projet c'est que c'est surtout pour
les embêter la stratégie du grand paris
7 alors colombette j'espère qu'on embête
le très fortement ça c'est certain mais
je crois aujourd'hui surtout il faut
voir comment demain notre département
peut rester attractif et donc
aujourd'hui on ne se doit d'étudier ce
que j'aurais apprécié dans cette
réflexion avec le président bédié c'est
justement de pouvoir justement se dire
qu'est ce que l'on peut faire demain
pour les yvelinois faire en sorte qu'on
puisse donner les mêmes prestations aux
yvelinois
que ce soit pour les personnes âgées que
ce soit pour les personnes handicapées
que ce soit pour nos collégiens et que
je sois aussi pour nos infrastructures
il faut qu'on reste un département
attractif il faut que les entreprises
continuent d'avoir envie de venir dans
les yvelines
parce que c'est les avoir tous dans la
première couronne ça va pas nous
arranger non plus ce budget commun qui a
été voté pour cet ep i qui regroupe
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
nous étions présents lors du vote le
reportage aussi moins de cinq cent mille
euros en 2016 près de 14 millions
d'euros en 2017 et un budget commun x 30
les départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine poursuivent leur
rapprochement dans le détail cette année
et 12,7 millions d'euros sont dédiés aux
routes départementales 1 million à
l'archéologie préventive et 100000 euros
au service de l'adoption les
départements versent à l'établissement
public l'argent qui était consacrée au
paravent pour remplir ses missions à
l'euro près et c'est là donc dans un peu
plus de temps dans 18 mois sans doute
quand on aura la comptabilité de
l'établissement public que l'on pourra
voir si effectivement nous avons comme
ça réaliser des économies parmi les 88
élus départementaux 6 des hauts-de-seine
classé à gauche ont voté contre le
budget primitif dans les yvelines sans
opposition politique seul philippe
brillault s'est abstenu je suis
dubitatif sur la pertinence
parce qu'en fait vendredi dernier en
votant le budget des yvelines je n'ai
pas vu l'effet miroir de la diminution
des sommes que j'ai voté aujourd'hui si
nous avons voté aujourd'hui une somme je
dois le trouver en moins à proportions
respectives de nos chaque département je
n'ai pas vu également opposé aux
arguments économiques de la
mutualisation des agents de la cgt
s'étaient rassemblés avant le conseil
d'administration de le pays
il s'inquiète notamment pour leurs
conditions de travail une dernière
question sur ce rapprochement olivier de
la faire entrer yvelines et érode scène
est ce que finalement il faudra pas un
moment ou un autre demandé aux habitants
leur avis à référendum
alors là la question est déjà été posée
je ne sais pas si légalement on a le
droit de le faire aujourd'hui
en revanche en revanche c'est vrai qu'on
peut nous reprocher d'avoir pris cette
décision
en dehors de la campagne électorale mais
en revanche il faut il faut vraiment pas
oublier les incidents ce qu'on a pu
avoir notamment budgétaires derrière
toutes les incidences que toutes les
missions qui nous sont redonné de l'état
la redistribution aussi la loi notre ça
fait partie aussi des nouvelles
évolutions sur lesquels on doit regarder
moi je trouve que sept
ce rapprochement est vraiment étudié je
suis pas capable de vous dire
aujourd'hui s'il faut le faire ou pas on
va avoir un certain nombre de
d'arguments qui nous permettront de
prendre notre décision mais aujourd'hui
je pense que il est bien de pouvoir de
pouvoir y réfléchir nous passons à
présent la dernière séquence de est
cette émission du 7-8 politique
[Musique]
les élèves de terminale es du lycée
emilie de breteuil à montigny le
bretonneux qui suivent une spécialité
sciences sociales et politiques
s'expriment sur notre antenne depuis le
début de cette saison depuis mois de
septembre ils votent pour la plupart
pour la première fois en 2010 est
aujourd'hui c'est aymeric bonjour qui
nous a rejoints en plateau vous allez
exprimer votre regard sur la politique
sur les politiques
aujourd'hui vous avez rédigé un petit
éditoriale avec vos camarades vous
écoute bonjour alors on assiste à de
profondes mutations au plan politique
sur la scène internationale en effet le
bruit exit votée par le peuple
britannique pourrait fragiliser sur les
prochaines années l'europe politique
diplomatique économique et militaire
l'élection surprise de donald trump aux
états unis peut marquer un tournant
quant à la place diplomatiques de son
pays sur la scène internationale et
soulève des interrogations quant à
l'évolution de l'otan au rôle futur des
etats-unis au moyen-orient ainsi que sur
les controverses actuelles liées à la
délivrance de visas
il ya la politique migratoire menée par
le gouvernement actuel des états unis
enfin la poursuite en europe de la
montée des extrémismes avec l'extrême
gauche a mené par le parti syriza en
grèce avec alexis tsipras sa tête ainsi
que le parti espagnol podemos il est et
l'extrême droite polonaise nationaliste
porté par andrés duda prenons le cas de
la pologne en décembre 2016 rfi nous
signale que les députés des trois partis
d'opposition parlementaire ont protesté
auprès du président polonais duda contre
sa décision de limiter l'accès des
médias aux députés en outre d'après rts
le président polonais aurait confié le
pouvoir de nominer les dirigeants des
médias publics à l'un de ses ministres
des questions se posent temps ci sur le
futur de la liberté des médias sur
l'indépendance de la justice et la
séparation des pouvoirs judiciaires et
politiques ou encore sur le respect des
libertés individuelles
dans un monde instable il lors de cette
année électorale importante pour notre
pays
la france va-t-elle faire le même choix
que celui de certains de ses voisins
en tout cas en regardant les sondages et
les analyses réalisées par les médias
français
il semble y avoir chez nous comme à
l'étranger une défiance vis à vis à vis
des élites et des représentants de la
vie politique française en général avec
moins de 80 jours du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle un héros un
ancien est un enseignement majeur doit
cependant être soulevée en effet si la
confiance vis-à-vis des politiques est
en baisse
l'intérêt pour la politique en elle même
est en augmentation en effet les
primaires ont permis à six millions
d'électeurs cumulé après les primaires
gauche de gauche et de droite de
s'exprimer sur les urnes par les urnes
cette élection présidentielle souligne
l'opposition de deux visions divergentes
de la politique et du rôle de l'état
d'un côté nous avons l'idée portée par
benoît hamon et jean luc mélenchon
porteur d'une vision de la gauche
audacieuse et idéaliste encourageant un
état plus interventionniste plus
interventionniste dans l'économie et
accroissant son implication dans la
société
cette vision s'oppose à celle de
françois fillon candidat d'une droite
assumé et libéral favorable à un état
recentrer sur ses fonctions régaliennes
la défense les sécurité intérieure et
extérieure et la justice toutefois une
autre voix émergent celle d'une
éventuelle conciliation de ces
différences de vision celle d' emmanuel
macron pour rassembler au delà des
affinités partisanes au delà du fossé
idéologique qui sépare des candidats
quand même
benoît hamon ou encore françois fillon
dans le but d'éviter de diviser encore
plus les français donc dans un pays
aussi aujourd'hui aussi divisée que
peuvent faire les responsables
politiques pour recréer un sentiment
d'unité et redonner à chacun le sens du
politique et comment nous éviter le
danger du populisme en trouvant des
solutions forte et viable face au risque
d'une cassure irréversible au sein de
notre société
entre le peuple et ses représentants
sur justement la pause et olivier de la
fermer sa numérique en plateau ce qui
s'exprime mais est ce qui ressort c'est
cette tension qui s'opèrent aujourd'hui
avec les extrémismes de gauche de droite
qui parviennent au pouvoir dans
différents pays à travers le monde et
pas seulement en europe et comment pour
répondre à ces questions aujourd'hui ont
réussi à restaurer cette unité
moi je crois que c'était le côté positif
de cette primaire c'était enfin pour la
droite de pouvoir exprimer un vrai
projet ça fait très longtemps qu'on
savait plus ce que vous voulez faire la
droite où elle voulait aller un coup à
coup au centre un coup à droite un coup
au milieu
le projet de françois fillon il a été
une réponse très très claire de ce que
les français avaient besoin
il a fait quatre ans de terrain mois ce
qui c'est ce qui m'a fasciné un peu dans
son projet c'est ces quatre ans qu'il a
pu faire sur le terrain écouter les
français les problèmes des français des
entrepreneurs des agriculteurs et à
chaque fois il a sorti des idées enfin
après on aime ou on n'aime pas mais il a
sorti un projet il a sorti des idées qui
correspondait à leurs problèmes et je
crois que c'était ça la vraie celle je
crois que c'est ça demain la politique
dont on a besoin c'est de répondre aux
problèmes des français qu'on arrête de
nous faire de la démago à nous sortir
des grandes truc qu'on fera jamais parce
que ça coûte très cher je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait une
vraie une vraie vision des problèmes des
français
oui pourquoi les agriculteurs n'y arrive
pas aujourd'hui pourquoi il leur manque
un ou deux centimes sur le litre du lait
[Musique]
face à la face à la grande distribution
c'est pas normal aujourd'hui un
agriculteur et doivent pouvoir s'en
sortir avec ce avec le fruit de son
travail
aujourd'hui 1 une entreprise doit
pouvoir embaucher facilement c'est
toutes ces petites choses là aujourd'hui
que françois fillon a essayé de porter à
essayer de proposer sur la sécurité
sociale on l'a contesté aussi mais sur
la sécurité tient il faut juste regarder
comment on peut faire mieux et c'était
sa volonté comme on peut faire mieux
demain pour essayer de soigner plus de
gens et mieux et moins cher
je pense que c'est ça la réflexion
aujourd'hui on doit réformer un certain
nombre de choses on a une admiration qui
est hyper lourdes en france qui qui qui
empêche beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
et notamment nos entreprises qui
voudraient qu'on leur fiche la paix pour
pouvoir travailler mieux pour pouvoir
faire faire faire de façon beaucoup plus
1,2 pour embaucher c'est la seule chose
là dont on ne les prenez votre candidat
est celui programmé sans partisane est
vrai c'est normal mais mais mais pour
répondre à la question est là j'ai aussi
posé la question et briques aujourd'hui
les discours en dehors des extrêmes des
discours qui sont tenues que ce soit à
gauche que ce soit à droite vous semble
aller dans le bon sens en tout cas pas
vers une tension d'extrémisme est ce que
ça peut apporter des réponses est ce que
vous en tant que jeune pour 2017 vous
allez voter pour la première fois
l'affairé cette haine vous devrez pas
encore voté là pour 2010 7 mai mais
concrètement ça vous rassure les peuples
les politiques qui sont portaient les
paroles qui sont portait quand vous
entendez au lieu de la faire par exemple
je trouve que chacun veut défendre son
candidat c'est sûr mais même les
discours
au lieu de nous réunir des discours nous
divise de plus en plus en faisant porter
une voix de gauche plus en plus à gauche
et une voie de droite plus en plus à
droite
la rencontre a une volonté de rassembler
vers le plus par le centre du coup
aujourd'hui faudrait surtout se
rassembler sur un projet est voté sur 20
et voter pour un projet plus qu'un
candidat des gens
pourquoi l'extrémisme est monté aussi
c'est parce qu'on les attendait avec des
idées très forte que ce soit la gauche à
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui est effectivement et nous et
la gauche et la droite on avait tendance
à continuer d'avancer parce qu'on était
au pouvoir
les uns les autres ils sans jamais se
poser les vraies questions ce dont
avaient besoin les français je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire on l'a vu dans le débat de la
primaire de gauche on l'a vu dans le
débat la primaire de droite aujourd'hui
ce qu'on essaye aujourd'hui c'est juste
une clarification des tarifications du
paysage politique et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui si on les écoute vraiment
et ça c'est là je veux dire c'est ce que
je voudrais dire aujourd'hui rue en
septembre de la fin c'est ali écouter
les projets les projets les programmes
des différents candidats et rendez vous
compte que aujourd'hui on a pour moi et
en ce qui concerne françois fillon il a
vraiment un projet qui correspond aux
problèmes des français et qui veut il
veut y répondre parce qu on a eu trop
pendant trop longtemps on a laissé faire
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut tout
bouge et il faut tout réformer gens
qu'on puisse aller mieux demain et faire
en sorte que les français soient
contents verra comment les discussions
vont évoluer on espère qu'on reparle en
un peu plus des programmes que des
affaires dans les prochaines semaines
sur ce plateau et sur toutes les autres
antennes nationales merci à tous d'être
venus c'est la fin de cette politique
à très bientôt sur notre antenne
[Musique]